[Música]
[Aplausos]
vengo a traerles
dos noticias
una buena y otra mala
aunque la mala no tiene por qué servicio
necesariamente como algo malo
ni malo ni bueno es algo normal lo más
natural del mundo
lo que pasa con determinados temas
es que si no se aborda
si no se encara
si no se trata
es como si no ocurriera nunca verdad
bueno digamos entonces que le traigo dos
noticias una buena y otra y otra menos
buena vale bueno
empiezo con la menos buena ahí voy
un día nos vamos a morir
no me mira si usted también
y usted y usted y toda la fila 7 que se
está metiendo de la abuela silla aquí
que no se esconda nadie que no se escapa
nadie
un día nos moriremos todos yo también si
sirve de consuelo
saben cuál es la buena noticia
que los demás días no
no sé si conocen a snoopy y a charlie
brown ellos son los que nos ponen en la
pista en esta viñeta genial de jules de
su creador y es que vivimos en una
sociedad que está totalmente de espaldas
a la muerte
el mero hecho de hablar de ella
provocan angustia
y te dejo un mal cuerpo
y eso que el amor perdón la muerte
esa horrible costumbre que tiene la
gente de morirse
es tan segura como inevitable desde el
preciso momento que nacemos
de hecho nacer es su antítesis
no es vivir
porque lo contrario de morir no es vivir
lo contrario de morir es nacer
porque la vida y la muerte son la misma
cosa en la cultura oriental por lo menos
lo tienen clarísimo clarísimo la muerte
forma parte de la vida
al menos desde un punto de vista
filosófico por mucho que diga la rae
la muerte forma parte de la vida es la
etapa final del viaje
pero es viaje es vida al fin y al cabo
verán
cuando yo conocí a antonio antón ya
tenía 92 años
cuando te llegan los papeles los
informes médicos
y te pones a leer toda esa palabrería
médica escrita
tratas de hacerte una idea de cómo va a
ser la persona a la que vas a acompañar
en el final de la vida y siempre te
equivocas saben por qué
porque faltan los momentos que tiene que
compartir posteriormente con ella
durante el viaje
falta
falta la biografía porque somos biología
pero como diría nuestro querido profesor
ramón bayés somos biografía somos el
viaje
antonia
nos esperaba en el salón de su casa con
una sonrisa bondadosa
una cabeza clara como pocas con la edad
que tenía y con el cariño de su hija de
su marido y el marido de su hija de su
yerno
de su nieta de su nieto
antonia clínicamente estaba bien
entonces charlábamos un poco y ella nos
contaba cosas y releía su vida y nos
decía algo así como
pero yo que pinto aquí
he tenido una vida plena completa he
criado a mis hijos con muchísimo
sacrificio pero sido tremendamente feliz
mi marido se murió hace cuatro años y yo
releo mi vida y llegó a la conclusión de
que tenía una vida completa
y
yo creo que ya me podía ir no les parece
y yo le escuchaba y yo decía claro que
me parece pues sí sí me parece me parece
que cuando has tenido una vida completa
plena y estás esperando a cerrar el
círculo vital de una forma lo más
armoniosa posible
mereces
concluir
que cuando te llegue el final
lo puedes perfectamente abordar con
calma con la conciencia de haber vivido
como dicen en los pueblos del
guadalhorce con la campaña hecha
y antonia
con su familia con el calor de los suyos
con su idea y su mente clara de 92 años
tuvo una espera dulce
y se fue
como vídeo
sin hacer ruido
yo creo que es fundamental que todos
tomemos conciencia
de que la vida nuestra vida
es finita
pero háganlo con naturalidad
porque eso les va a ayudar a disfrutar y
a poner en valor los momentos que viven
en el día a día
porque aceptar
que nos morimos algún día
le da pleno sentido a nuestra vida yo
llevo 14 años en cuidados paliativos y
estoy intentando aprender a naturalizar
la y todavía sigo intentando aprender
porque no es fácil
pero que nadie dijo que fuera fácil
cuál es la primera conclusión que
sacamos de todo esto
pues yo la primera conclusión que saco
de todo esto
es que se muere como se vive y que la
gente necesita ha llegado el momento
coherencia en el final de su vida
necesita coherencia porque si vamos por
la vida con miedo a vivir
tendremos miedo a morir
pero si llegado el momento concluimos
que hemos tenido una vida plena una vida
completa y aceptamos como dicen mis
pacientes del guadalhorce que la campaña
está hecha seguramente ese momento lo
viviremos con mucha menos
con mucha menos angustia no le parece
y me preguntó
si morimos como vivimos porque no
vivimos con amor
porque no vivimos con amor
vivir amando y siendo amados
cuidando y siento cuidados
cuidado tenemos una palabra más bonita
en nuestro diccionario algunas la brass
tan bonitas como esa pero más bonitas no
cuidado viene del latín cogí tattoo
pensamiento fíjense qué cosa más curiosa
cuando cuidamos a alguien
lo tenemos en el pensamiento lo quitamos
lo cuidamos
lo tenemos presente
en el paciente en el final de la vida
probablemente
una de las caras más amables que tiene
el amor porque el amor tiene muchas
caras en el final de la vida una de las
caras más amables y más dulces sea
la compasión
dice la antropóloga budista joan halifax
que la compasión es inherente al ser
humano
y está dentro de todos y cada uno de
todos ustedes pero que necesitan unas
condiciones particulares para que se
active
yo creo que eso fue lo que le pasó a
joan hunt
joan hunt inglesa dirigió varias
empresas
inglaterra y decide cuando llegue a su
merecida jubilación que se viene con
sufre de su arma
a disfrutar de su merecida jubilación a
españa
pero no a cualquier parte de españa
andalucía
los hermanos
y decide venirse a la costa del sol y se
viera fuengirola
llevaban muy poco tiempo fue girola
cuando fred le detecta un tumor cerebral
hospital y está en el hospital de la
cruz roja de málaga y muere poco después
que cree que hace yo
lo primero que hace joan es hacer una
colecta entre la comunidad inglesa de la
costa del sol y poner cortinas en las
habitaciones del hospital porque decía
que eran inhóspitas
que eso era inhumano
pero cuando cae en la cuenta de que ha
perdido ofrece llega a la conclusión de
que fred no ha fallecido como a ella le
hubiera gustado
y que las personas que parezcan la misma
enfermedad de fresno deberían de
fallecer como falleció ofrece y de
repente chas salta el clic salta el clic
salta la compasión que tenía dentro
latente
a partir de ahí con la ayuda de toda la
comunidad inglesa de la costa del sol
johann funda la fundación cudeca
de cuidados paliativos
a la que tengo el inmenso placer y
orgullo de pertenecer
y que se encarga desde hace 26 años de
atender a las personas con enfermedad
avanzada y terminarla
eso hizo joan
en todos estos años que han sido 14
he vivido muchos casos muchos muchos
casos
en los que el amor ha fluido en todas
direcciones
me acuerdo de juan por ejemplo juan
moribundo sin comer ni beber desde hacía
varios días prácticamente sin respirar
el equipo médico da un pronóstico vital
de unos 2 días
su hija maría dentro de diez días
juanes pero qué
juan espera a que su hija para 12 días
después
a que esté los dos o tres días
preceptivos de hospitalización ya que a
pie de cama le diga a su padre de papá
aquí está tu primer nieto para morirse
amor con amor se paga
esta historia
me tocó la fibra sensible
la de alberto
del athletic
servidor del athletic aunque tengo la
camiseta del cádiz que pone zona franca
en mi casa
con alberto hablaba muy a menudo de
fútbol y alberto me decía cuando vaya a
madrid te voy a traer el vicente
calderón un regalito alberto empeoró y
falleció
me estremezco de pensar
el momento en el que su esposa dos
semanas después cumple el deseo
de alberto en forma de bufanda del
atlético de madrid
que ha presidido la silla media de
trabajo durante años y que mis
compañeros pueden dar fe
antes hablamos de compasión
no quiero que tengas la idea de que la
compasión es pena o lástima porque aquí
la raíz se vuelve a equivocar la
compasión es una acogida la compasión es
recoger el sufrimiento de otro y tratar
de aliviarlo
eso es la compasión
hay personas con enfermedad avanzada y
terminal que sufren
y que no tienen los recursos suficientes
para abordar ese viaje
y estas personas necesitan de la
compasión pero desde un punto de vista
altruista es decir necesitan de usted y
de usted y de usted y de usted y de
usted y de usted
necesitan de jon hamm o de alguien como
ella necesita de la comunidad
afortunadamente
se han puesto en marcha un montón de
ideas a mí hay una que me parece
maravillosa a través de organismos y
otras instituciones se han creado
comunidades compasivas son comunidades
de personas que ayudan a paliar ese
sufrimiento en personas con enfermedad
avanzada en situación
en situación de favorecimiento
donde no hay recursos suficientes para
atender los comunidades compasivas en
españa'
new health foundation creó ciudades
compasivas mediante acuerdos con
ayuntamientos
salem cuál fue la primera
sevilla
les quiero
hacer una invitación para terminar
no esperen que salte el clic
no esperes
búsquelo
convierte a esas situaciones normales en
particulares y propicias para que para
que la compasión ya se salga amén
cuide
entréguense la vida
la vida es un regalo que se nos da
unos dicen que es regalo de dios otro
ala otro mago más y después estamos los
escépticos que hablamos de la naturaleza
o del azar pero es un regalo que se nos
da
es un regalo que merece la pena ser
vivido así que viva claro que sí viva
pero wieman con amor
porque con amor
seguro
seguro seguro seguro que va a ser mucho
más fácil más emocionante y más
gratificante vivir
y morir mucho
[Aplausos]
[Música]